[Music]
mobility the movement of people in
places across short to long distances
requires liquid transportation fuels and
that feel mostly comes from petroleum so
the question is what do you do about it
how do you address the needs that you
have for energy for fuels with the fact
that you have a demand problem and
increasing supply and also this
overarching issue of trying to be
environmentally responsible so that's
the problem into this reality comes
biomass but why biomass well first its
abundant report in the u.s. over the
past decade estimated 40% of our liquid
transportation could be supplanted by
biomass derived fuels how do we address
the need for fuels for mobility in the
context of a need of biomass for food as
well as water to the support that
biomass keeping in mind the fact that we
already have hundreds of millions of
vehicles on the planet or require liquid
transportation fuels and how do we do
this in the short term on a timescale of
much less than 50 years one of the
advantages I think anyway of biofuels
the ability to move rapidly towards
providing alternatives we focus on
microbes which are very small living
systems and those are naturally able to
take sugar and convert them into
molecules we can use as biofuels one of
the first concepts we teach to chemical
engineering students is the principle of
conservation of mass energy simply put
you can't use more than you have the
balance between using crops for food and
using crops for fuel so one approach to
the food fuel conflict is simply not to
use food crops in order to produce
biofuels that won't be enough we'll
still have to cultivate new crops and we
need to do this in a way that doesn't
require the water intensity that
currently exists for agriculture and in
force of materials that are intolerant
to drought we also have to think about
how do we cultivate new crops in a way
that's not labor and energy intensive
how do we get the speed in terms of
having alternatives without doing
further damage so it's already a
precious commodity in our
and how do we think long-term about the
same time trying to have short-term
solutions and the other thing we have to
think about is scale we have to be able
to take ideas from a lab into the real
world our goal is always to make more as
fast as possible as cheaply as possible
the other thing that we do is to
genetically engineer those organisms to
make compounds they've never made before
to be able to engineer plants to be more
easily degraded in fact those plants
express their own enzymes that result in
this degradation and they're not
activated until after you harvest the
plants this results in a plant that's
easier to cultivate as well as one
that's much less expensive to process
once you have those sugars what do you
do with them this is the focus of work
in our lab and many others at MIT we're
using advanced tools of metabolic
engineering and synthetic biology to be
able to create custom design microbes to
convert these sugars into replacements
for diesel and gasoline that are
compatible with our existing
infrastructure so that again we address
the problem of the cars that we already
have this is cutting-edge science if we
are successful in our goals we'll have
the effect of drastically reducing our
consumption of oil but it also will
result in really reducing the admissions
that we're putting into the environment
which is resulting in the climate change
that we see around us
[Music]